let's talk about excellent campaign
video blows you away get you to donate
the campaign goes nowhere 31 days expire
whatever the length you look at it and
it's this depressing amount and you're
like how is this possible
that will all be in the outreach so if
you have a really fantastic crowdfunding
video and and it's you know pulling at
people's heartstrings
the only reason there's they're not
contributing well I'll say this
number one is maybe that's a fantastic
pitch video by someone standards but not
by the standards of the audience that
are actually there for the movie so
there's that piece but if it really is
like an exceptional crowdfunding video
I've never seen an exceptional
crowdfunding video know one time I did
actually one time on season spark
probably still the best crowdfunding
video I've ever seen in my life and the
campaign went nowhere and that's because
they did zero outreach and nobody saw it
right so you can't just make an
excellent crowdfunding video and put it
on a website and hope that somebody sees
it it is your responsibility on any
platform to drive traffic and you start
with your friends and family that's your
first 20 or 30 percent in why because
strangers like to pick a winner
they need to see momentum and they need
to see inevitability of success right so
you can demonstrate the inevitability of
success by making a kick-ass
crowdfunding video the momentum you have
to generate from your community first
which is why it's a really good idea to
build a crowd so you're not just going
to your friends and family but your your
immediate community is already people
who are like yeah I want to see this
thing right so that by the time you want
your campaign you're not just limited to
your mom dad uncle and like a couple of
your brothers banker friends so that
immediate crowd again was those people
that got involved with the process of it
yeah when you launch let's say your
Twitter or your Instagram whatever
quotes you most and saw your whatever
tweets about a similar situation that
you're gonna do a story about or yeah
those are the people okay absolutely
and then outreach is what outreach has
many components outreach has there's
direct outreach and that is everybody
that you can reach by email oh I have
start by saying this so social media is
not a means unto is not a means unto
itself or an end unto itself social
media is a tool for getting people to do
stuff
generally speaking the highest
conversion rate to watching a movie
contributing to a campaign will come
from direct emails so actually think
about it as concentric circles the
outermost concentric circle is all the
people you don't know that's most of the
people inside that is everyone you can
reach through social media and you can
grow that capacity right but it's not
entirely reliable a lot of times its
feed based or its algorithm based so
when you tweet something it's not
guaranteed that a hundred percent of
your followers will see it when you post
something on Facebook God knows how they
display it to people like it's a that as
a secret hidden behind lock and key even
when you pay for it so social media is
good but thanks to the power of the
smartphone you can reach everybody by
email and if they're really excited to
get your emails they will open them and
read them right so I never look at
social media as like once I get to
200,000 Facebook followers I'm done
because I've seen campaigns with 200,000
Facebook followers fail right getting
people to like you on facebook only
proves that you can get people to like
you on facebook right if you can get
them to like you on facebook can you
then get them to sign up for a mailing
list because you're giving them some
sort of reason or incentive to do so and
then once you reach them in their inbox
will they click on the stuff that you
send to them this is all easily
trackable through all of the tools that
are available to us now it doesn't take
a rocket scientist trust me because if I
can do it anybody can do it so what's
really important is to be able to
increase your direct outreach capacity
so part of the pre-campaign build up is
to try to really grow your email lists
primarily and whether that's because
you're doing a ton of outreach through
social media and then you're getting
people to sign up for your
email lists or it's because you're
partnering with people who themselves
have email lists organizations things
like that so the first part of your
outreach is direct how many people can
you reach in their inbox and what is the
work it will take to reach all of the
people you can conceivably reach in
their inboxes and I would include
indirect outreach actually Facebook
direct messaging Twitter direct
messaging you have to be careful with
that because if you just copy and paste
to everyone number one Facebook will
shut you down and number two you're
likely to kind of insensitively send
somebody something that may not be
appropriate like if you're not paying
attention you might send your
crowdfunding campaign to your friend
who's like I just lost my mom or your
friend who's like I have no money or
whatever or that happens to me all the
time I'll get sent a crowdfunding
campaign for a film that's crowdfunding
on another platform and I'll be like bro
do you even read things not that I don't
contribute on other platforms I'm just
like did you but did you consider the
delay anyway so so it's important to be
very sensitive to who you're reaching
and gathering all the materials it takes
to reach out to them so you want to like
bring all of the message tested language
together the images that seem to have
really worked with your audience the
music that seems to really work with
your audience the videos that have
seemed to really work with your audience
and get the text as concise as possible
because when people open emails they
need to get to the decision-making point
quickly right the emails that you wait
to write until 2:00 in the morning
always end up being the like long ones
of why I got into film in the first
place and to be honest basically nobody
but your mom cares right so get to the
most concise bullet points of like why
me why this why now why you communicate
that make sure that every time you send
an email it also includes immediately
shareable Twitter and Facebook language
that you have precomposed so you can
turn me from my inbox to a social media
evangelist with two clicks let's face it
most people are reading those kinds of
emails while they're sitting on the
toilet
they got one hand free they were there
if you if you can help them share stuff
with two clicks of a thumb you're gonna
get them to share stuff right so your
direct outreach is really about getting
people in their inboxes and also turning
them into amplifiers right that's one
phase of outreach and usually there's
like three categories of direct outreach
for a personal outreach the first is the
people you're basically sure are going
to contribute to your campaign
it's like immediate friends and family
who will support anything that you do
you're gonna reach out to them well in
advance of launching your campaign
you're gonna tell them about what you're
up to you're gonna get them to commit to
contributing you're gonna find out how
much they might be willing to contribute
so you have an idea of where you stand
on day one that's really important and
if one of them says like I'm in for
$2,000 you're like great can we run a
matching campaign in the second week of
our campaign to see if we can turn that
2,000 into 4,000 and incentivize people
to get involved in the second week of
the campaign so you can keep up your
momentum so you're gonna get a sense
through your direct outreach of what
you're gonna do on day one and you know
maybe there's some options and
opportunities in the second and third
week of your campaign for bringing those
larger contributors in a little later I
mean there's the second set of people
who you're like maybe with a personal
email they will get involved and you
need to really look at how long is that
list and you got to pool the resources
of all of your filmmaking team how long
is this list because if it's two or
three hundred emails you're not gonna
send them all in one day
you need to send two or three hundred
more or less personalized emails that's
part of the work that you're parsing out
for yourself in the campaign you're
organizing I'm gonna I'm gonna commit to
sending ten per day right giving
yourself something that you can stick to
as opposed to something you're gonna
procrastinate on until the last week of
your campaign then you're gonna send a
bunch of desperate emails that aren't
very effective they're gonna be those
long diatribes
horrible and then the third category is
kind of like everyone you've ever
emailed ever that's accruing in your
Gmail inbox and you can create like a
MailChimp list and just check in with
people and make sure they want to be
subscribed to it and then you can kind
of blast them a couple times throughout
the campaign come what may
right that's a good way to start your
mailing list there and then any
organizational out
so anybody who's willing to put you in
their newsletter or send you out to
stuff you have to give them the
materials they need to succeed as well
the organizational part in the outreach
is the most important part you need to
be prepared in advance with not only how
you're doing all your direct outreach
but how you're keeping your social media
feed fresh your Twitter feed while your
crowdfunding can't now devolve into only
self promotional tweets you need to keep
up about a nine to one ratio and that
means you still need to be in the
conversation the ideas around your film
maybe around filmmaking or around the
topic of the film that you're making you
know for dear white people for example
it's really easy you can get into a lot
of like interesting comedic takes on
race or social justice they have a sort
of a clear conversation they can get
involved in figuring out what that is
and making sure you're still maintaining
that takes a plan right you have to have
either somebody who's doing it or
somebody who's researching it or you do
a bunch of research in advance and you
say okay I think these are the topics
we're gonna really focus on each week
these are the audience's we're really
gonna try to reach each week we're gonna
focus a lot on Twitter because we know
we can reach our like young women
interested in social justice there but
actually like if we really want to get
to like the filmmaker crowd they're
actually largely on Instagram so we're
gonna do this thing on Instagram for
that audience and then there's this sort
of like baby boom generation who's very
interested in you know seeing versions
of themselves as children that they
never got movies that never got made
when they were children sort of like the
sort of nostalgic thing and they're more
reachable on Facebook right and so this
is going to be our campaign on Facebook
you've got to have a plan for your
social media to keep it fresh to keep it
interesting if you're tweeting the same
in week four that you were in week
one we are bored and probably have
unfollowed you right so you have to have
a plan for that as well
and your updates that every crowdfunding
platform has a an update function it's
kind of like a blog but let me be clear
people don't subscribe don't
let me be clear people don't contribute
to crowdfunding campaigns - just like
subscribe to blogs the point of your
updates is to show progress to
demonstrate further inevitability of
success to keep up the momentum to bring
people deeper into your your world and
the content should be visual and
shareable in exciting ways you have to
make your updates easily shareable
whether you're using click to tweet or
your pre composing shareable language
all the time everything that you're
doing should increase the virality of
your campaign the share ability virality
is dumb because like you can't you can't
predict virality all you can do is try
to increase your chances to achieve it
you